what's it like serving on the front
lines of the response to the corona
virus pandemic and what if the federal
state and local response has gotten
right and wrong so far to answer those
and other questions reason turn to dr.
Jeremy s Foust of Harvard Medical School
and Brigham and Women's Hospital in
Boston where he trains emergency room
doctors and is pulling daily shifts
treating patients who have kovat 19:00
Faust stresses that attempts to reopen
businesses schools and other parts of
everyday life will need to be based on
local conditions and that effective
containment has to rely on the voluntary
participation of people who are given
reliable information rather than ones
who are bullied by political and medical
authorities it's not a weather system
that we contract beginning middle and
end says Faust we make the weather if
people believe in what their
participation is he says it's a hell of
a lot easier to achieve containment than
through some sort of draconian
enforcement Faust also co-hosts the foam
podcast about ER and coronavirus issues
and writes for brief 19 a daily review
of kovat 19 research and policy Jeremy
thanks for talking to Reason glad to be
here thanks for having me so I you know
tell tell me to paint a picture of what
is going on in emergency rooms and ICU
units or you know intensive care units
across the country or at least and where
your work the number one thing that I
could say is there's an incredible
diversity of experience whether you're
in New York where people are stretched
to the very limits of what's possible
and doing in being thrust into
situations that they never were prepared
for to places like where I am in Boston
where it's really different than
anything we've ever done before but more
or less it's so far has been doable in
the sense that we can respond and be
nimble to the to the threat and change
the way we do things in order to keep
everybody safe
so the I think the tremendous diversity
of experience from city to city state to
state just reflects the few things the
resources that are available and the
number of cases
and really this is the important thing
who gets affected because that can
change everything so let's start with
that what do you mean who gets infected
you know everything that we read or most
things that we read is it's
overwhelmingly older people you know
people over 65 or at the highest risk of
dying from this and of having really bad
reactions is that true or is that not
quite nuanced enough broadly speaking
that's that's accurate I think the data
has consistently shown that over 65 and
especially over 80 you have a massive
uptick in in fatality from this disease
now what we think is so different though
and this is where I get into these sort
of who gets it matters by and large the
way I would say it is this if you have a
thousand people who get the virus and it
was say at a college that hadn't shut
down yet versus a thousand people who
get it in a couple of nursing homes a
thousand cases in one place at thousand
cases in the other I would expect very
very few fatalities in the younger folks
and and and then a ton of fatalities and
the older folks and the implications for
that other than just statistics are
actually really important because the
hospital just receiving these patients
is going to have a very very different
experience so if I receive a thousand
young people I'm gonna find a bunch of
people in that group who who need help
but I won't be stretched to the limit of
my ICU capacity I won't be having to
choose which patient goes on a
ventilator and which one has to just die
in front of me that would be a situation
which you would have if this thing had a
thousand cases out once in a nursing
home or in a few nursing homes so that
is when I when I look at these curves
and these fatality numbers it's always
important to remember that the piece of
data is a piece of data a narrative is a
separ from them so what are we what are
we getting right as a country about the
response to coronavirus and and where
are we just you know either making it up
as we go along or heading in the wrong
direction well one thing that I would
say is that because of how contagious
this virus turns out to be which was far
more contagious than the initial
estimates that we were told the need for
this shelter in place and incredible
degree of social distancing us far more
evident than what was initially thought
because if you had even with a the
numbers that you saw it was going to be
scary but it wasn't on a nearly as bad
as I think that we see and so because of
that you these these shelter in places
and these in these kind of extreme
social distancing is quite necessary in
certain areas and since we and this is
the part we're not right because we
don't know enough about prevalence data
all across the country we can't be more
nuanced we can't guess and so if we knew
ok in this city it's so low that we can
do some degree of social distancing and
in this city it's so high that we have
to dis completely shut down because we
don't have that information that the tie
goes to the scarier scenario in order to
save lives
so in this as usual more information
would be better so we would know what to
do and so what I would say we're doing
well is that when you look around
especially where I live
people are abiding by this I think the
right I'm a little surprised and
pleasantly surprised to see that people
are staying home there's no traffic you
hear these stories and you know Spring
Breakers going and doing crazy things
but by and large I think people get it
and that's been really encouraging I
think it shows that people are willing
to participate in something that's not
convenient if they think it's for the
greater good
so that's one thing we're doing well is
that were responding to what we see and
in a in a way that I think is I hate the
word used use word a patriotic but
almost humanistic is that look even if I
am not worried about getting the virus I
am worried that I'll give it to someone
else so that's what's going well I think
what's not going well as the testing
having a strategy for that and I think
that it's it's something that we could
have prevented there's very little I
think we could have done that was as
practical without the hindsight being
20/20 it's easy to point fingers but we
knew this virus was a threat the
sequence the genomic sequence was
available in early January and this and
I think when in the final analysis the
who knew what about our testing capacity
when will be the million-dollar question
in terms of like how did this get
screwed up so royally in terms of that
part of it but other things I think were
very hard to a predict it because of the
contagion and other an end of course the
ace
dramatic transmission there symptom-free
people being able to spread it I can't
you can't point fingers of that that's
that's something that we didn't know and
I don't think was appreciated and is so
unusual you know so with the testing is
the problem like we went from zero tests
to a million tests
I guess relatively quickly even if it
should have started earlier what's going
on now because it seems like that the
number of tests has not grown
particularly well do we need different
tests or we do we need more of the same
or what what what would help resolve
that there's a couple of ways to answer
that question it's a little bit of both
so it's well stated the the reason I
think that there's a couple of reasons
why testing numbers are not increasing
sufficiently and one is actually a
little bit of a unequal demand so I
think that we've heard even stories that
some of the commercial laboratories are
saying hey we can run more tests why
aren't there why aren't we being sent
more tests and that could be because in
certain areas they are there is an
excessive test they're actually like
where I'm working right now how it's
changed a month ago I had to beg the
Department of Health for a test and they
would say no and I was like are you
kidding me like I need to test this
person they got it or I think they do
now I don't have any real careers for
the most part in my emergency department
I want to test so for me I don't think
that there's a bottleneck on in our area
in that way but I'm sure but I know
across the country had colleagues who
still can't who can't do these and so if
if you could wave a magic wand and have
the test be where they're needed and
that would be great but I'm worried that
the reason that they testing isn't
increasing is the places where it's
needed most don't have enough tests and
I can't tell you why that is but I do
know that we seem to have enough in some
areas and not enough in other areas and
again that's where surveillance from the
CDC would have been helpful they're just
now doing that but they didn't we don't
have enough information to know that do
you are I mean are you a strong critic
of the way that the CDC and the FDA have
kind of handled the oversight of the
testing regime so far or is that
something that's not worth discussing at
this moment what I would say is that I
don't know enough to be able to make a
really informed opinion on that but my
sense from people who do is that
for whoever's fault it was whether it's
the CDC or external factors that
affected the CDC but the testing the
early testing problem senator senator
round around them and I don't know to
the extent the FDA would have played
into that I know that now the FDA is
doing a better job in terms of fast
tracking tests
I think the CDC is now doing a better
job of surveillance but so I wouldn't
necessarily want to cast blame per se
but I do think that we had policies in
place that didn't allow for alpha and I
think that was a unfortunately a
life-death inducing mistake because we
we know and I wrote about this almost a
month ago now it's time to kind of fly
but we know that if we can if we could
do all this test thing you can tell
people who are young and healthy hey
look you've got it and you don't even
realize it or maybe you thought is a
mild thing or flu that's oh don't give
it to the nursing home and so you know
don't go to work because you're a
healthcare worker or whatever it would
be so that that to me is unfortunately
the where that's all started and it
against your question I think it's how
we get out of it - both with the kind of
testing to ramp up and increase
availability where it's needed and of
course the next thing two more things I
would say one is to start to figure out
how to use antibody testing because
right now we test for the virus's
genomic material genetic material so we
do that's called a PCR test and that
that's a pretty good way of knowing if a
patient has the disease or not although
it's not perfect and then the antibody
tests with their blood tests tell you
you exposed at any point how how immune
are you we're still working out all
those details but knowing how much there
is in terms of antibody prevalence in
communities will be very helpful because
if I find out that it looked my entire
town seems to have had this already and
it's 90% of us have the antibodies you
could open right up right we just have
to know both quantitatively and
qualitatively where we're at with that
and then the the final piece and this is
a really a little more of a nuanced
argument in the even in the absence of
what I would fantasize about which will
be like there's tons and tons of tests
for everyone all the time like you know
just you want it you got it like you
know a billion test you know three per
person or ten per person in the country
and
you can find out that may not be
practical but you do start to be able to
guess or make a good estimate of how
things are going if you have a pretty
wide testing regime and you start to say
what your what your hit rate is so right
now you see like if I if I test somebody
I feel like I mean I'm making this up
but you have more than half the people
that I test will test positive and that
means we're not testing enough people
there not enough people coming to the ER
or wherever else whereas in New York
it's starting to fall so we used when
you get to a point where you're doing a
random surveillance and a very very tiny
fraction of people actually have it then
you can say okay we're on the tail end
of this thing I'll give you an example a
study just came out in the New England
Journal the other day and every single
expected mother who was getting admitted
to a hospital in New York was to scream
like 200 and something women who were
about to give birth and they just said
we don't care if you have a symptom or
not we're gonna check you out and it
turned out that nah not surprisingly
fifteen percent or so actually had it
which is crazy high number when you
think about it but given what we know
about New York may not be so surprising
what was remarkable is that eight times
more people had no symptoms than
symptoms hmm and now that may not expand
out to other populations and we know
these are people who've been interacting
with the healthcare system so they might
have a higher likelihood than than you
and me or whatever else well actually I
have a higher one um but all to say that
when you when you start to see your your
batting average you're sort of hit race
you hit your hit percentage drop below
to one percent less than that then you
can say okay look these are needles in
haystacks not everywhere you look so you
know there's been a lot of discussion
about the idea that and you know with
the the premise is that once you have
the disease you are immune to it and
you're not going to transmit it so you
can go back out to the population
there's some questions about that how
serious do we need to be taking that
yeah that's a question that I have to
watch with you as well in terms of the
immunologists and the specialists on
that particular issue but the way I
would summarize it for people who are
trying to kind of get their mind around
it would be to we all have the
experience of having our vaccinations as
kids or as adults and then you might
have to get
your blood drawn once a while to get
what's called the titers and this is to
say okay you had your musil's mumps and
rubella when you were a child
are you still are you still immune or
not and the numbers depending on the
virus which correlated to okay if your
numbers are at this level we think
you're good and that's what we need to
kind of tease out here which is so we'll
get a yes/no pretty quick pretty quickly
on in their coming weeks or months about
how many people were exposed and all of
this the question will be is it if
everyone has the antibodies is immune
for how long what does that mean that's
gonna have to be teased out by by very
rigorous studies but these are studies
that thankfully we actually know how to
do you know I say we I mean the system
what you can you describe what what do
you do in an emergency room situation or
in an intensive care unit what are you
doing for patients when they come in so
the number one thing that I can do as an
emergency doctor well there's that
there's so many different things the
first thing is any e/m doctor emergency
medicine doctor is we save life we save
limbs we save organs and that's what we
do so regardless of whether it's coated
or whatever it else is it's the first
thing to do is to stabilize the dying or
the nearly dying patient if that's
possible and if that's consistent with
what they want some people made very
clear they don't want to be put on
machines and they want a natural life of
a natural death so that's number one and
so when a patient comes in and they're
having near they're about to die from a
respiratory failure then and they want
to be we assume that they all want to be
saved although again this is where goals
of care and most forms and all this sort
of things the advance directives living
wills then what I can do as an ER doctor
is to stabilize them and give them
increasing amounts of oxygen whether
it's do masks or or I can do what's
called intubation which is when we put a
patient asleep very rapidly we paralyze
them temporarily I put a breathing tube
into their near their lungs into their
air pipe and windpipe and and get them
the oxygen they need so that's the so in
terms of the critical critical illness
it's an oxygen issue it's an agent it's
an oxygen delivery issue and however we
need to do that is there's the way to go
and there's other detail
sales of this disease we're starting to
see other more blood clots do we need to
be more aggressively treating that are
there other infections simultaneously so
that's the that's the big thing that the
next big thing is essentially it's a
resource utilization in the sense of is
the patient in front of me assuming
they've got coronavirus do they actually
have disease that needs to be looked
after in the hospital in the clearly if
they need to be put on a ventilator
that's a pretty easy decision
but the other ones the ones who sort of
look a little uncomfortable they need
some oxygen they might need some other
treatments maybe their blood pressures a
little dicey yeah can I turn them around
and send them home or is like oh no I
need to watch these for longer so it's
it's essentially it's a risk we call it
risk stratification and and to know okay
who who among the people I send home are
gonna do poorly if I do that who among
the ones if I keep them could go the
other way this is what another thing I
argued another article if we overdo it
we can harm people right so if I admit a
patient today who has a yeah a
reasonable but low chance of having had
a stroke in the past 24 hours a month
ago I would have admitted that no
problem even though maybe it was not the
best if you really did a risk benefit
calculation I was kind of on the
borderline but we have to be careful
because of a lot of issues including
litigation and including standards of
care
but today that same patient if I if I
admit them to the hospital I'm really
really saying well I think that whatever
is going on with your possible stroke is
more important than the risk of you
getting coronavirus while you're here
and that is a very different calculation
which is why I say everything's
different we have to know we have to
follow the data and be nimble of that so
a lot of it is a decision process of
who's served where and and the most safe
way and we're getting more and more data
on that but it's still a lot of it's
just a judgment call can you talk a bit
about the case fatality rate and yeah
because that was I think the first
writing of yours that came to my
attention and you I guess it was like it
you know you say like a month ago or two
months ago that seems like 10 years ago
at this point but you were arguing in a
paper and in
you know that the case fatality rate the
number of people who have the disease
who die from it is almost always going
to go down because in typical pandemics
as you do a fuller accounting the number
starts to go down what what is your best
estimate at this point of what a case
fatality rate for coronavirus in the
u.s. is and is it going up is it going
down and does that matter at this point
well I am a very data-driven kind of guy
it's hard for me to make up for
addiction but what I would I would what
I would like to do is to to break this
into two parts and I think that we're
gonna and I think people should watch
this they should look at a case fatality
rate for people who essentially
initially had very mild symptoms and may
not have even been tested at first so
put it this way the case fatality rate
for people who don't even know they have
it or just got sick at home and they
think they had I'm quite sure it's
almost gonna be zero because that's why
they never got tested and discovered so
there's a huge pool of people who have
the disease that we don't even know
about and none of them die right and
then you take a couple of them out who
progress and get worse in the nation up
to the hospital and then you look at
that pool of people that's the second
bullet of people who show up at the
hospital in among that group you can
start to look at these numbers again and
say ok what is it 1 percent it's 2
percent is 0.1 percent point 2 percent
and again you have to put both of those
pools together in order to make an
overall shape a palette II so so one way
we could look at it would say patients
who were admitted to the hospital what's
their case fatality rate patients who
were seen at the hospital and sent home
how did how many of them came back or
died at home what's their case fatality
obviously much much lower and then the
third piece is people who never even
knew they had it will figure this out
the antibody testing and through other
ways and then you put all that together
and my assessment is you're gonna see
something far under 1% and but still
over 1% for that really sick group an
older group but for the most people
it'll be far far under 1% which leads to
the I think the inevitable question if
it's point 5 percent point 2 percent
point 6 percent whatever anything under
1% is within order of magnitude
apparently of seasonal flu
seasonal flu they tell us is point one
percent so how can this thing if it's
point five percent how did this thing
this be five times worse than flu when
what we're seeing to our system is not
five times worse it's a hundred times
worse than anything we've never seen
before and that's where again really
good data matters unfortunately the zero
point one seasonal influenza a number
that you hear is not accurate it is a
gross overestimation of no influenza
deaths so what you're saying is that
it's not necessarily that the novel
coronavirus is that much worse than what
we think but it's that we have been
overestimating what the what a typical
flu season produces without without a
doubt yes and um I'll be writing about
that more in the coming days and weeks
I'm not gonna scoop myself too much on
that but what I will say that's an area
event of actually massive importance not
just because of academic like Oh which
is worth which is better but actually it
could because people say things like oh
it's sixty thousand deaths is what the
new revised thing is that's what killed
flu last year mm-hmm so it's just
another flu and people and people who
aren't in the hospitals are in high
prevalent areas sort of shrug it off as
like maybe oh this is kind of you know
hysteria or making a big deal out of
nothing cuz they're not seeing with
their own eyes
and so that's an incorrect comparison
because you have to actually compare and
this is what I'll say you have to
compare counted deaths to counted deaths
and the 60,000 deaths due to influenza
are not counts that they're estimated
and they're based on many assumptions
and coefficients and multipliers that
are used by public health officials to
make what they think is a good estimate
but I think is probably being shown not
to be and and and it's but it's for a
laudable goal they want to give
vaccinations they would want to tell
people the hygiene matters and so over
selling the flu over the years had a
kind of a public health benefit I would
I would say but today yet the president
out there and and even a month or two
ago we had the Surgeon General who I
think is a very intelligent and measured
guy saying oh just as bad as you know
this will be no worse than the flu to
the numbers well no they're dead they're
due they're wrong and the implications
are gigantic if they if people use
that information to say okay well just
another flu let's open the economy and
that would be devastating so what what
do you think and I realize this might be
outside of your area of expertise or
comfort but where do we need to be
before we can say okay let's open up the
economy or is this also going back to
your earlier statements is this really
what we need is more regional or more
location specific data because what's
going on in Boston or the Greater Boston
area in New York and I don't know you
know someplace in Kentucky these are
radically different environments and
should be treated differently that's
that's what I'm saying yes and I will
just use New York and Alaska as the two
extremes right the Alaska is an
important part of our economy and the
caseload is obviously much lower and and
just in general the the risk of a rapid
spread is lower because just this the
density and so one of the problems with
New York is it such a vertical town and
everyone lives in the same place they
taught the same elevator buttons I mean
it's a recipe for disaster
so you can have you need a much stricter
and slower
we reopening a place like New York than
you do in Alaska even if you could
measure everything perfectly which of
course we can't do so what I would
advocate for is a slow reopening that
state by state or region by region and
also situation by situation and and some
some of it's a matter of two there's two
things to think about one is how
necessary is the thing three open right
you can make different arguments about
what was considered necessary and what's
not so you can have a little bit of a
higher-risk fresh hold for some
necessary things or a lower threshold as
opposed to sooner open right on the
other hand you could say well look this
is also a low-risk situation even if
it's not that useful like some been
using silly example that like the Boston
zoo where a bunch of kids go yeah I
don't necessarily see why they can't
reopen relatively sooner knowing that
you just say okay look usually we allow
a thousand people in per day and this
month we'll let a hundred people in per
day and one's gonna stay apart and and
we're gonna watch it carefully because I
believe it's some reopening in this way
would be really beneficial for the well
for the economy but also just for our
society
I do worry you see these protests like
you know we want to be free let us out
of our quarantine I think if you ask too
much of people for too long there's this
rebound effect where they rebel it's a
it's a it's in our nature to not want to
be quarantined and so the sooner we can
safely do these things the better but
each situation is is completely unique
could you talk a bit about what you
think the legacy of this and obviously I
mean we're still in the thick of it so
it's it's a little bit forward to do
that but what is the effect going to be
on patient autonomy I mean do you do you
think is this a place where the medical
profession or the public health
profession and political scenarios will
say you know what we need to do is to
give patients more information to make
individual decisions where is this going
to have more of the effect of saying
individuals are not the people who
should be making the decision here it
should be a larger yeah it's an
important question um there's so many
different nuances to that for one the
big-ticket item here with autonomy is
gonna come down to vaccinations is if we
have a vaccine that works and there are
people who are refusing it what do we do
I think that's gonna be a really
important question and it's it's always
been kind of hypothetical in the sense
of oh we're gonna have a resurgence of
these pediatric diseases and we actually
and then in some cases we've seen it for
real right so we've had to go through
and say okay I'll religious exceptions
enough no that's changed so that needle
moves
I'm very as you are and I'm very
interested in to see where that goes
because again I think that the right to
your own you know autonomy as a as a
person as a patient does is pretty broad
but I don't think it goes so far that it
means that you can put your neighbors at
risk if that risk is real if that reason
was real you know if it's like you know
you can you can imagine an insane
situation if someone didn't understand
HIV and they said oh I don't want to
live next that person in the next
household they have AIDS and I don't
want to get AIDS like that would be very
ignorant but the point and that would be
an extreme example of that your autonomy
is not so important you know like if
you're the neighbor who believes like
you know you're going to get infected by
the neighbor where as a very
communicable disease there's a point it
is you know then it's like well actually
sorry we have to we have to do this you
know we have to say what is right and
what is wrong so that's the big thing
the next thing I would say in terms of
the economy question it was a medical
information I think that in general I
think that we've been moving towards
more medical information so that that's
for the better one thing I think that
one of the legacies that I would turn to
that we haven't really touched on but I
think it would be interesting to you and
and I think this this this listenership
and readership is the issue of medical
science in general and research and
we're seeing this just an astronomical
number of research papers coming out
about coronavirus and Cova 19 sure not
precisely the same thing once the virus
and once the syndrome
and the the peer review process is
something that really needs to be looked
at I think we've had situations in which
in the past I'm very familiar where that
the system has been really effective and
in times where it's been it's been
hijacked by people who are trying to
make money and in this case I think that
what's the real concern I have is that
even among my colleagues my physician
colleagues who are supposed to be like
scientists
sort of a little bit of throwing the
scientific method to the out just so you
don't forget it so the examples of well
we need something let's just give these
medications out and I that very at
worries me greatly that we are that we
run this situation is unmasking some
degree of scientific illiteracy among
some of my colleagues and even in very
intelligent places because there's just
this intense desire to do something good
but sometimes we have and there's
there's a bias that we carry that we
think that we help more people than that
we think that what we do is more
beneficial than my videos even though I
think there's benefit and we think that
the way we've hurt people
is less severe than it is so you know we
always the lawyers chase us down when we
didn't do enough but they never chased
us down when we did too much and they
should they should take just down for
both and in fact I think they're doing
too much there's probably
way underreported and doing too little
is probably over-exaggerated I think
that one will try so that's that's a big
thing it's to stick to the scientific
method I'm very very worried that people
are saying oh I heard an anecdote about
this drug or that John Huggins we're
gonna give it out without any really
good science and that's the part where
I'd like to see a course correction it's
a final question you you've talked about
the pressure on people when you ask them
to do too much to stay quarantine to
stay lock down and it and it has you
know psychological effects on people how
are how are you and your colleagues you
know who are dealing with us on a daily
basis how are you guys holding up and is
there is there a psychological strain
that is that gets to be too much or you
know how does that play out the
psychological strain that my colleagues
I have is only related to a safety at
work if there's not enough personal
protective equipment then where people
are really worried the rest of it I
don't think we're worried about going in
fact I think I think we have it easy
everyone else is stuck at home I'm just
going to work like normal you have do
you have the personal protective
equipment that you need and does that
you know does that short is seem to have
been taken care of or well we're
rationing like crazy so I have not yet
encountered a situation here where I
felt unsafe but I never thought I'd be
rationing so that's that's but movie
also in but you see in New York
different places where it is unsafe
that's real so in terms of the stress on
us I don't I don't feel stress I think
it's easier for people like me because I
just know what to do I go to work and I
just stay safe it's much harder for my
family like sticking home they're not
directly part of this and that's where
people people get antsy when can this be
over when do I get to go outside when it
can be free and I think that the the
number one sort of thing I'm learning
here is that there's a way to get people
to to effectively participate in these
strategies that we know to work is not
to force them to do it although if
necessary I guess is what you try to do
but is it because that's not gonna work
the best way to get people to to
participate in these strategies is to
have them understand why they're doing
it and have them want to do it and so
it's almost like the way the yes we can
sort of war effort you know like you
know
live in a time during World War two and
people remember like what it is to like
conserve for a greater cause but I think
that there's a sense of the greater
generation that they wanted to do that
in order to help the war effort and I
sort of feel the same way here it's like
even if you had enough police in the
world to say it to save one at home and
do it you know
authoritarian governments could maybe
accomplish I don't think that would work
I think the best way to do it is to
basically appeal to people's sense of
reason and duty and then it's just a lot
easier to do something difficult but you
know why you're doing it and you have
essentially a part of it so I do try to
actually kind of inspire people to think
about that doing nothing is doing a lot
and it's very appreciated because it's
not it's not a weather system that we
can track beginning middle and end we
make the weather and so if I think if
people believe in what their
participation is it's it's a hell of a
lot easier to achieve that then you know
as some sort of draconian sort of
enforcement
dr. Foust thanks for talking where's the
best place for people to follow your
your thoughts and actions on all this so
well Twitter activity past but the I
have a daily blog with a bunch of ER
doctor and policy wonks called brief 19
and that's brief 19 calm and at brief
underscore 19 on Twitter and what we do
is we do a two days a two page executive
summary of the research and policy
currents that as we see them and we try
to put all those crazy papers that are
coming out into context to say okay the
whole divorce is like here's what it
says let's not get ahead of ourselves
and then the policies I try to track
what what we think matters and what it
means so it's for dr. sources by doctors
but it's written in a way that we hope
is not just for health care
professionals but also for the the
mainstream sort of to light bulb on
viewer or reader and and that's been
really successful so that's the best way
alright thank you again we're gonna
leave it there dr. Jeremy Foust thanks
for what you're doing and for joining us
today
yeah great to be with you thanks so much